President George HW Bush Secretary of
State Baker National Security visor
Brent Scowcroft did a brilliant job of
ending the Cold War without war they
helped Gorbachev relinquish his own
Empire in Eastern Europe and then helped
him dismantle the Soviet Union while
people in this country was screaming you
know Gorbachev was a commie this is the
time to tell him what to do if they had
done that there would have been a
reaction from within the Soviet Union
and none of this stuff ever would have
happened you'd still have the Soviet
Union today but they handle the demise
of the Soviet Union by helping them kill
themselves off another brilliant active
diplomacy so it's not as if the spark of
genius existed only in that immediate
post-cold war era existed at other times
because the essence of it is good common
sense and that's that's what we really
need now you know a couple months ago
this country went crazy over Sully
Sullenberger I went crazy with Sully
Sullenberger what did he do he landed a
plane safely in the Hudson River and the
country thought this was absolutely
marvelous well it was absolutely
marvelous because it was an act of
simple competence and they this had been
seen so rarely in our country that they
went nuts over a guy who exhibited it
and this used to be the hallmark of
America and Americans pragmatic
problem-solving common sense and
competence